we are now going to try to understand a
very important concept about circles
look at the circle divided into two
equal parts how do we find the area of
this colored part let's assume that the
radius of the circle is R units you are
familiar with the area of a circle and
we can see that it covers half the
circle so the area will be half
multiplied by PI R squared this is the
area of the circle and we multiplied by
half to find the area of this colored
part now look at this circle which is
divided into four equal parts what will
be the area of this colored part it will
be 1 by 4 multiplied by PI R squared
since the area of the circle is split
into four equal parts we multiplied by 1
by 4 let's look at another part of the
circle this part what would be the area
of the colored region in this case
without any information we cannot find
the formula for the area of this part
more importantly what we are trying to
find is the part of the area of a circle
these colored regions are called sectors
you may think of a sector as a pizza
slice a sector is covered by two radii
and an arc in the first case these are
the two radii and this is the arc in the
second case these two are the radii and
this is the arc and in the third case
the sector is covered by these two radii
and this arc coming back to the question
how do we find the area of the sector
the area of a sector is proportional to
the angle that the arc subtends at the
center it is called the sector angle in
the first case this sector angle is 180
degrees hence the area of the sector
will be 180 by 360 multiplied by PI R
squared out of the total 360 degrees
these two rate
I have 180 degrees between them this
value is the same as this value as the
ratio equals 1/2 similarly since the
sector angle is 90 degrees in the second
case the area of this sector will be 90
by 360 multiplied by PI R squared which
equals this so if this angle is 30
degrees then the area of the sector will
be 30 by 360 multiplied by PI R squared
this part is the area of the circle and
this part tells us how much of the
circle is covered to generalize the
formula for a sector we can say that if
the sector angle is Theta then the area
of a sector will be theta by 360
multiplied by PI R squared